Wouldn't it be wonderful if
the data we were using for
our analytics was perfect?
It would save so much time just
being able to blend it together and
run with it.
But that almost never happens.
Usually when we get data, there are
issues with it that require us to spend
large quantities of time to clean it up.
We get a file that hasn't
been parsed properly.
Maybe there are multiple columns
all appearing in a single column,
which we'd need to fix.
There could be junk in a field,
like strange characters
that we need to clean up.
It's also possible to have duplicate
records appear in your dataset.
All of these issues make it difficult
to just use the data directly.
And they all require
some level of effort for
us to clear up the problem
before the data can be used.
In this lesson, we'll look at the most
common issues we find with data.
We'll discuss some approaches on
how to address these problems, and
practice cleaning a few datasets.
By the end of this lesson, we'll be able
to identify problems in our datasets,
like missing data and outliers.
And then use some of the techniques
we've learned to clean them up.
Clean data sets will put us on the best
path to building successful analytics.